oui mon pote et guay oui ma fille est
lesbienne deux des cinq affiches lancé
il ya quelques mois par santé publique
france contre les discriminations subies
par les personnes lgbt plus une campagne
qui n'est pas passée aux yeux de
certains versaillais en mai trois
personnes dont une conseillère
municipale écrivent au maire pour lui
demander de retirer les affiches de la
ville coupable je cite d'exposer aux
yeux de tous des situations sexuelle et
familiale qui n'ont pas à être promu ni
encourager pour leur répondre le
collectif versailles lgbt a organisé une
action dimanche 13 juin au marché notre
dame
c'est important sa campagne c'est santé
publique france il ya des chiffres il ya
des jeunes qui se foutent en l'air parce
que ils sont dans un mal-être total de
ne pas être ce qu'ils ont envie d'être
de peut-être se sentir rejeté deux
peut-être vivre de l'homophobie et qui
se foutent en l'air qui se suicident
versailles n'appartient pas qu'à une
certaine catégorie de population
ça appartient à tout le monde
et à partir du moment où en fait il y a
des lois on peut pas aller à l'encontre
de ça et on ne peut pas aller contre une
campagne du gouvernement en 2019 en
france 35 % des personnes lgbt avait
fait l'expérience d'au moins une forme
de discrimination
trois fois plus de tentatives de
suicides enregistrés ces douze derniers
mois chez les lesbiennes les gays et
bisexuels que chez les hétérosexuels à
l'occasion de leurs actions versailles
lgbt a reçu le soutien du député des
yvelines didier baichère ça m'a semblé
naturel de venir les soutenir
donc on a une opportunité à versailles
de donner un message positif aussi sur
ces sujets pour beaucoup de jeunes qui
souffrent de ces discriminations qui
souffrent de l'homophobie parfois qu'ils
présentent comme dans beaucoup de villes
françaises
le collectif a profité de sa présence
sur le marché de versailles pour
remontrer les affiches de la campagne de
santé publique france et sensibiliser le
public présent je trouve que c'est une
super campagne et qui est contente
voilà d'ouvrir un peu les coeurs et les
esprits je suis né à versailles
il ya maintenant quarante neuf ans et
comme beaucoup aux pommes comme beaucoup
de monde
le refuge c'était émigrés j'allais dire
à paris et parce que versailles était
une ville avec une image homophobes les
chances qu'il faut casser cette
exception versaillaise qui est
déplorable qui est le fait d'une petite
minorité n'est lors du premier
confinement le collectif versailles lgbt
va se constituer en association dans les
prochains jours